avant première des affamés à elancourt
au ciné cette c'est l'occasion pour les
spectateurs d'échanger avec la
réalisatrice du film
une rencontre organisée dans le cadre du
festival les images vagabonde
un événement à l'initiative de
l'association contre auchan ça fait
partie de notre dynamique d'action
culturelle menée tout au long de l'année
on fait pas mal de choses et donc c'est
le moment de contrechamp mi juin et c
est un moment qui maintenant pour nous
est inscrit dans notre calendrier
d'action culturelle on dire au programme
de ces quatre semaines des oeuvres
cultes mais aussi des nouveautés sur le
thème d'un monde meilleur à l'image des
affamés le film qui sort le 27 juin met
en avant une jeunesse en délicatesse
avec les études et les débuts sur le
monde du travail réalisé par les affres
de vannes il est incarnée entre autres
par l'actrice et chanteuse luan aimera
[Musique]
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai compris je
ne sais pas juste une catégorie d'âge
c'est une place sociale
nous devons tout sans rien obtenir les
changes je voulais représenter je
voulais que ce soit des gens qui soient
différents les uns des autres qui se
retrouve de part leur génération et de
par leur âge mais qui viennent de
milieux différents quais des couleurs de
peau différentes qui est des aspirations
différentes aussi est effectivement dans
le film on a un banquier une agence
immobilière
un dj un journaliste voilà il ya toute
forme de deux quêtes le cinéma cette
participe pour la deuxième fois au
festival
outre les affamés plusieurs films sont
proposés de la science fiction au
documentaire en passant par l'animation
les visiteurs auront libre cours pour ce
faire une ou plusieurs toiles clap de
fin le 13 juillet prochain